fun fun conversation topic uh about
Japan go on yay so I um I saw this
article uh and it was a Japanese article
about a Japanese thing and I I want to
know your reaction and opinion on it
yeah so
it was an article
and basically a guy a kid uh like a 15
year old kid had stolen uh like a plug
extension cord like a five dollar play
extension cord yeah from a store and his
parents found out right so his parents
called the police and called like made
him apologize and give the thing back
um and that was their way of like
teaching him and punishing him I guess
yeah because he stole so stealing's bad
and you should get arrested for it sure
yeah
um what I was surprised by was would you
reckon the the Japanese comments were
like what do you think the the overall
thoughts were on on that move uh on the
parents calling the police
yeah what do you think what do you think
how do you think the Japanese people
reacted to that okay okay first of all
question how do you react to that what
do you what do you think we don't want
to hear that it's a bit excessive
I mean what do you think you think it's
good setting an example or do you think
it's Overkill
um so the pair is called the police
right so that they found out that their
son uh had stolen this like plug
extension yeah not from like a friend's
house or anything from a store right
yeah so he's shoplifted yeah yeah
another if your friend makes any better
but if I stole a PlayStation from show
me like that don't worry about it I
wouldn't call the cops
you stole it from a store right which
feels way more like oh okay yeah uh so
yeah he stole it and then they they
called the police and obviously he
doesn't get like he doesn't get jail
time or anything because yeah he's a kid
but you know just a slap on the wrist
right yeah and get scared and
interrogated for a while yeah what do
you think how how would you how do you
feel about that do you think it's a good
move I feel like calling the police is
kind of like going a bit nuclear yeah um
I would get him to return try to return
the extension core to the store if
you're doing anything else and you know
being completely being completely honest
with the store members to be like this
happens
um we're bringing it back he's sorry
yeah you know if he can don't you know
yeah we'll pay for the chord whatever
you know I feel like and then I would
rinse him when I get home yeah oh oh
[ __ ] yeah it's just really dry yeah yeah
but definitely like at the very least
get him to apologize to the store
members yeah and stuff like that that's
right amicable if you can't
um I don't know what I would do I feel
like in in my head I see that as
them
I don't know if this is like fair I feel
like you're just kind of making your
parenting obligations and putting them
on the police like you're doing the
parenting right because you're like like
ah [ __ ] yeah scare him make him make
him feel bad about it right it's like I
don't know couldn't shouldn't if he's
your kid shouldn't you kind of install
these beliefs and then you know punish
him or give you I don't know I feel like
it's not going that far I think because
he needs to learn that he has
consequences for wrong actions I think
the least okay
I think the belt is still yeah I think
police is a little bit extreme but at
the same time you know I feel like the
parents are taking the boy to the police
you know to see to show them that there
are consequences which I think is
different from some examples I've seen
where parents are just like you know
other people should just handle this you
know teachers need to teach better and
discipline my child and stuff like that
you know
um you know because I think there's a
big difference between you taking an
active role into taking the the person
to see what the consequence of their
action is versus wanting someone else to
completely take over for you yeah yeah
so what was the uh Japanese reaction
then uh the from what I saw they were
like oh my God the parents are so brave
and a lot of people were in agreement
and the general consensus was that it
was a really Brave and really honorable
thing that the parents did Brave yeah it
was Brave that's Brave about it
I guess because they I don't know
because most Japanese parents would just
be like or maybe just take it back I
don't know I to me it's like it's weird
because I think that you know I feel
like the police are [ __ ] better
things to do or they I'm not I don't
know about Japan but generally right
because like oh finally yeah like I
don't know I feel like the police should
do real stuff and not I mean I mean I
feel like this this might work for Japan
just because maybe only in Japan could
you imagine in the UK if you did this or
America they did laugh at you they'd be
like get the [ __ ] out of here yeah stop
wasting our time I got to deal with like
actual [ __ ] happens yeah like apparent
your goddamn kids yeah um no I I agree
though with the whole thing of like it
is up to the parents
I think that this is coming from three
dudes we don't have kids yeah I just
think when I when I heard this my
initial reaction was like oh wow nice
wasting police time great yeah no I
agree God I also read now this was on a
Reddit it wasn't an article so take it
with it is like a
a I think it was a reaction no it was a
foreign couple with uh one of them was
Japanese one of them is far yeah and one
of them was far the foreign guy was
pushing on Reddit being like what the
[ __ ] what is this yeah so I think it was
on it was one of the Japan reddits
because I just love keeping up with them
seeing what seeing what fun stuff's
happening yeah and um
uh this uh his daughter that was like
eight to ten years old had taken an
eraser from a store and the store owner
called the police right on the kid yeah
and the police uh like interrogated the
kid for like three hours
because I stole an eraser and then were
like taking apparently we're taking like
uh well they were like oh don't worry
though we won't we'll put in the system
but it was bad that I'm laughing we
won't send it to HQ
they were like what the [ __ ] you just
got a traumatize this you're trying to
teach him unless you're trying to teach
him a lesson I just wanna I just want to
see the scene of like the kid coming out
with the cuffs and the towel over the
hands I think it was like so what
happened to us sorry um so what happened
that the mother made the daughter take
theater I remember that yeah mother made
the daughter take the Eraser back to the
store okay I made them apologize like
you said yeah don't apologize get back
and the store owner caught the puck the
cops
from that right and it was like whoa in
my mind I read that I was like Jesus
Christ imagine you're like oh dude I'm
sorry I'm my daughter she's you know she
didn't you know just stole it no you
know here it is yeah you're like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I'm calling the police I'd be
like whoa yeah that's all that's an
[ __ ] move on the story yeah I mean
lawfully he's rightful to do so but you
know morally it's like very [ __ ]
excessive yeah I just again what a what
a [ __ ] week it's like a 50 Cent
eraser and they're just like yeah cops I
mean it's I mean the kid's got to learn
somewhere right the kid has to learn
yeah but like no I'm talking about the
store owner the kid has to learn and you
know he's not your [ __ ] kid so you
can call the [ __ ] police but you know
you can be like this is your chance to
be like a good like good A Good
Samaritan showing a good example of the
you know to the kid of if you admit to
your wrongdoings they're you know there
can be consequences but there is also a
chance for forgiveness as well you know
I'll just like that's that's that's my
take that's my take has like not
developed at all the kid yes maybe the
kid will steal and then he will learn
that this is very bad and my God the kid
will very much learn now yeah but then I
think that's too excessive yeah but then
I feel now the kid is going to be scared
to do anything but yes the guy on Reddit
was basically asking I think he was kind
of asking like hey how can I like how
can I Lodge oh yeah how can I Lodge a
complaint or get something done like it
was because I don't like they they were
like this is [ __ ] up like and I I
don't know the law is but I it seemed
even for Japan that that was not what
you were supposed to do yeah that's
pretty much that is way overboard that
was like a brother moment they literally
like apparently he said for three hours
they were questioning her and they
wanted to question her without the
mother there but the mother was like
absolutely not yeah that's [ __ ] up how
do you oh no question how do you you
found it yeah I found it they made a
writing confession
so they made her write a confession and
they took the mug shot of how old was
the kid
oh look oh my so wait can I can I can I
read it out the full story because this
is just it was so insane could you
imagine getting a mug shot down at six
years old I did not do this story
Justice okay okay
so it finally happened had my first
police experience and not in the way I
would have ever expected my six-year-old
daughter stole the racer from a
stationery store okay when her mum found
it around an hour later she marched her
back to apologize and the upstanding
storekeeper young dude early 30s called
the cops
and he said he's going to call her
school
he's there's a store and he's going to
call the school offered to do it
actually since he said the cops probably
well Cops show up and they continue the
forced March to the police station they
interrogated her made her write a
confession and took her mug shot they
actually wanted to do it without the
mother in the room and the mum said [ __ ]
that they said that since she's under 14
they won't be sending her file to HQ the
whole ordeal took around three hours all
girls crying and shaking the whole time
her mom isn't doing much better I know
you'll be asking for the details here
I'm not Japanese her mom is I wasn't
with them she never stole anything
before no I didn't punch the storekeeper
no I didn't punch my fair call is blue I
like walks on the beach great so I think
he was kind of asking like uh it was
really sounded sad as well I was like
the kid is okay on the surface but the
thing
yeah the kid is doing okay on the
surface but the first thing she did when
she woke up the next morning was to wash
her cups that were in the sink which
makes me think that she still feels
guilty and she's in trouble we're
working on that it's like what the [ __ ]
man this story is insane
seldom believe he has a reason to lie
about it on the other side am I the
[ __ ] so I just interrogated this kid
for three hours am I the [ __ ] I was
bored I had nothing to do with work so I
thought [ __ ] it but that dude I was
excited as my first interrogation how
how do you like this is It's just insane
sick six years old I I I can it's it's
sad to say I can totally believe this
being a real story here just because
again it's like you know we've talked
about the most True Pen thing ever yeah
Japanese police are for the most part
bored as [ __ ] because there's barely any
crime that happens they're often joked
about being online I've seen this a lot
about being just babysitters because
they often don't yeah
do much and they kind of enforce very
odd stuff like this yeah exactly well
like
I guarantee because like
I feel like this would cat this could
happen only in a place like maybe like
Japan or somewhere like that because the
store owner calling the police kind of
like matches up because it's just like I
don't know what to do it's not my it's
you know I'm just following protocols
the protocol was for the police you're
six years old I do not see it I just see
a stolen eraser therefore how do you see
a six-year-old girl returning this less
than a one dollar a race and be like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh this [ __ ] this
[ __ ] police
yeah maybe maybe he had like a weird
like false sense of like justice being
like if I don't stop her now she'll do
it again it'll just get bigger and
bigger and bigger so I have to stop her
at the arrest where's like the Japanese
Better Call Saul like spin-off what the
mom calls Saul like you're on it this
child is six years old your honor what
is the kid like genuinely what is the
kid gonna take away from like being six
years old and traumatized I just don't
understand well she'll never go into a
stationary store for the rest of her
life
can I borrow them
I just like I just read that [ __ ] and I
was like what the [ __ ] dude yeah
Jesus Christ ten levels above excessive
yeah
um yeah
I bet I don't know if yeah maybe some
Japanese people be like dude mom's so
brave the place
for taking a risk and then just putting
his safety in Jeopardy by calling the
police on a sexual I just don't I just
don't I mean I yeah I think isn't a
racer really worth it like I just I
assume I don't know how maybe that
they've had stuff robbed all the time
this was like the final straw yeah I
don't know but like it just felt like
it's like this is like not the battle
Yeah on average ADN yeah like it's
nothing it's not even a dollar it's like
it's just they're coming back to say
sorry yeah this is the kid that you
don't call it like the kid that you call
the cops on none of them but like the
person that you should be is the one who
tries to get away and doesn't come back
exactly if somebody's coming back
there's a there's they clearly care yeah
it's clearly a [ __ ] yeah why would you
and then clearly for the most part won't
do it again so just like it's not like
it was a like a Louis Vuitton bag right
oh my my five-year-old daughter stole
the Declaration of Independence sorry
it's like no it's like this was come on
man I know that theft is like looked
down upon way way way more harshly in
Japan than than say Western uh countries
it's all crimes wow not all crimes you
eat corn dude they're so okay so I
obviously there's a whole whole thing of
if it's a fine it's not a crime for the
rich right yeah that's like the and
there are a lot of stuff in Japan where
it is find where you would get prison
time and like our country like so like
um
um like in America right drink driving
is like a misdemeanor right uh oh no
sorry it's a missing in Wisconsin
Wisconsin has a it's very leaning like
in the UK and Australia I think and yeah
America you go to jail uh even if you're
over the limit but Japan's like two
limits there's one where it's like a
little oh come on give them more fine
little Mario you can't drive for a few
months I think there's two can you look
this up there's one where you definitely
like full-on punishment lose your
license but there's one if you're over a
limit you don't really get much for
punishment it's a fine and in Japan
finds on considered criminal no they're
they're transactions yes so the way it
works is that like you don't if you pay
the fine you're done the transaction
yeah the transaction is over yeah yeah
it's pretty odd and there's a few other
crimes it kind of sounds like legalized
bribing in this sense doesn't it if if
you describe it like that
officer officer if I give you an extra
thousand yen we
oh my gosh
um
that's for the which limit is that is
that the one there's two limits right
there's one depending on which blood
level your alcohol is hold on did you
say 500 000 Yen or a three years in
prison
yeah oh I think it's and and three is in
prison okay I was about to say if it's
all yeah I don't know who's gonna be
like guess always three years behind
bars instead of paying five grand the
same if you refuse to take the protest
okay but it doesn't say specific there's
definitely like laws in Japan that
aren't punished as severely as other
countries and there's stuff that is
punished way harder than other countries
yeah like anything with children for
example
Japan is uh just like a little slap on
the wrist everywhere else it's like
you're going to jail yeah yeah I I
there's I mean I don't know the specific
specifics of it but obviously even like
um I mean not depressing but it is very
depressing I think it's important to
mention it yeah of course there's no um
dual custody laws in Japan so if you
divorce it's often like you know it's a
bit bit sus and also like domestic
violence is pretty bad here and it's
very underreported because a lot of the
times they're just like well nothing we
can do yeah guys there's no evidence
guys you didn't do it yeah um and it
kind of sucks I mean obviously the
Western countries like that as well but
I know that certain punishment for
things and again off the top of my head
I can't remember which ones but I know
there's certain crimes that should be
punished way more yeah like I mean like
sexual crimes aren't taken nearly as
seriously as in other countries
you know it's pretty it's pretty sad
it's [ __ ] up yeah